on a dark evening when you look up at
the stars you might see the glowing band
of light we call the Milky Way this
region of the sky is so dense with
interstellar dust and stars it blocks
our view of a huge portion of our own
galaxy we know in general the shape of
the place we live but the details have
been obscured until now researchers have
finally been able to sneak a peek at the
parts of the sprawling spiral arms that
lie behind the core of the Milky Way
galaxy
unlike visible light microwaves can pass
through these cosmic obstructions using
the very long baseline array of radio
telescopes scientists found a peculiar
microwave source on the other side of
the galaxy the source was found in a
region of the galaxy where stars are
actively being formed by measuring
positional shifts in these microwaves
against the stable background of distant
quasar galaxies researchers discovered
that this distant microwave source lies
20.4 kilo parsecs away about 66 thousand
light years following the spiral from
the source to the center of the galaxy
shows that this microwave source is part
of the scoot 'm Centaurus arm of the
Milky Way while we might not be able to
see what's behind the galactic center
with optical telescopes measurements
like these can eventually help us to
fully map out the Milky Way galaxy and
with better Maps our galactic selfies
may become more accurate even if the
delta quadrant is still a little fuzzy
you